on a demandé aux internautes de voter
pour celle qu'il préférait dans les miss
et on a le top 15 vous allez voir la
favorite parce que ça va nous donner
déjà un petit quand même publique ah là
hé chéri on va voir une petite idée de
qui va être la prochaine Miss France en
15e position c'est Miss Limousin avec
1,9 % regardez c'est Salomé Salomé mode
Miss Limousin 23 ans qui est très belle
déjà en 14e position celle que vous avez
classé en 14e position c'est Miss
Réunion Miss Réunion
allez allez Marion Marie moto j'adore 18
ans Miss Réunion elle arrive en 14e
position Miss Picardie
voilà Esther Coutin
mais qui n'a pas été Miss
mais qui a été Miss Djerbala douce
l'embrasse
[Rires]
elle était en bas bouche
ça redescend tout de suite ça pose fort
ça te pose que si elles arrivent en
jabab bouche djellaba
c'est terminé merci elle avait gagné son
point en plus tâche on s'est éclaté tous
les deux
on va rentrer dans les 10 enfin on va
parcourir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça ferait beaucoup ça ferait des ordres
qu'est-ce qui t'arrive toi en fait
toutes les missions
[Rires]
de doc Miss Languedoc ah oui Cameron que
dixième
a été mise ici à Barney
je l'aurais mis un numéro une les
internautes l'ont mise en numéro 10 elle
est dans le top 10 Miss Languedoc
Cameron qu'on embrasse en 9e Miss Alsace
Miss Pays de la Loire
et maggiebert ça tient je vous le dis
il y en a une qui largement en tête vous
verrez non non après pas la peine de de
péter avant de dire quelque chose
septième position
merde
c'est fort franchement
5% seulement seulement
et là vous allez avoir une idée de celle
qui est la grande favorite le concours
Miss France parce qu'elle Caracol en
tête
quand je dis le caracole avec caracole
parce que ça veut dire c'est à dire
qu'elle est très loin de vous en
cinquième position c'est Miss Nord Pas
de Calais
[Rires]
mon ami et voilà apparemment c'est
peut-être je sais pas mais c'est pas sa
famille mais pas de sa famille
vous l'auriez vu si c'était de ma
famille on leur a vu dans les dîners
c'est pas du tout de sa famille d'accord
merci en tout cas tu as toujours les
infos
les infos people comme on dit j'embrasse
mon Seb
qui est beaucoup plus beau avec une
écharpe d'ailleurs je n'ai encore vu la
semaine dernière son beau tous les deux
en quatrième position c'est Miss
Midi-Pyrénées
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on va rentrer dans les trois premières
et trois premières en 3e position Miss
Lorraine
Miss Lorraine Sarah magnifique
magnifique
franchement non mais cette année c'est
la première année où il y a tellement de
de
Miss France là dans l'eau
parce que je voulais dire que elle était
très belle
[Rires]
avec
10,9%, je vous ai dit il y en a une qui
est largement devant qui a écrasé tout
le monde la deuxième c'est Miss Côte
d'Azur
[Applaudissements]
je me rappelle et non mais c'est vrai la
dernière fois il est venu et elle m'a
dit c'est pas rouge je dis c'est par là
la tête de suspense
qui
qui est la miss
qui a remporté tous les suffrages qui
est celle qui fait figure de grandes
favorites pour le prochain concours Miss
France
qui est celle
qui a obtenu plus d'un quart des votes
sachez qu'elle sait compter et qu'elle
est franche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
que je l'ai appelé tout à l'heure je
l'ai appelé au téléphone tout à l'heure
pour lui dire je vous jure que c'est
vrai je lui ai dit qu'elle était
première je l'ai appelé elle a répondu
[Applaudissements]
Delphine c'est la grande favorite toi
qui est un petit peu dans le milieu moi
je pensais oui franchement tu es ou
alors Martinique d'accord
Laura d'une Miss Monde
à Laura exactement merci alors voilà bah
je vous le dis c'est incroyable